Nói mình cảm thân một, lâu nắm các đặt khoảng 1.5,
trong mình sẽ nghĩ đặc đống quân tại Alaska trong tình trẳng sẵn sẵn chình khai
từ băng mini sột ta. Trời bối cảnh các cuộc biểu tình liên quan tới chính xanh
nực cơ của chính quyết liên quan tiếp tục liều tháng cả những tương này.
Héo 1.5, các đơn vị được yêu cầu chuẩn bị trước khi bản bạo lực ra
tăng, sau chơi có quy định quý cộng về việc yêu quan.
Đồng thay sẽ xa xúc khi tổng thống nước trong tây suả có thể viện giãn đạo lợt
đổi ngoại, để trên khai lực tưởng phần đổi, nếu chính quyết băng không kịp sát được
các cuộc biểu tình, nhắm vào lực lượng thực thi dí chú và hại quan AC.
Lần sống phần đổi bùng phá xong 2 phụ nột xong viên quan đặc vô AC tại
Miner Sota, nêm bẩy thân một ra người biên AC đả bảo chiên biên gớt 1 phụ nữ
Mỹ bàn bị gồi, khi bà đang ngồi trong ối tòa tại Miner Pilih.
Bà ngày sau 1 nối góc Vinicela bị bánh vào chân chung quá trình được lực liên
bàn truy quay, 2 phụ nột xong liên tiếp làm làm cám biểu tình phần đổi AC
Chính quyền băng nơi điều khoảng 3,000 nhân viên ai xí và lực lượng tôn chá biên giới tới Minapolis và Sanpau.
Và phía lên băng nhà chính bảo vệ việc tăng cường hiện dịt lực lượng nhà bảo vệ nhân viên và tài xả lý băng.
Chúc khi đó, thống đông minnesu ta chim quanh đáng huy động vệ mình khu sai để hỗ trợ lực lượng địa phương và bảo đam quyền biểu tình ôn hoa.